interesting you've been holding the
cards the whole time in your hands yeah
take a look
shut up
hey it's me jeremy and with the new
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness coming out on cinemas on the 4th
of may we are out here on the streets to
bring a little magic to people's lives
and learn a thing or two about the
upcoming movie so if you're ready let's
go so in the new doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness these are the 9
most rumoured characters that the
internet wants to see take a look at
them and if there's anyone that you know
pops up to you
i think the first thing that really
comes my mind is is the shield okay
we're seeing the shield i remember like
a girl carrying it right so
captain carter in another universe she
was the one that received the super
soldier serum and yes
correct
so before the mcu tom cruise was
actually slated to perform as iron man
to act as iron man so
internet again wants to see tom cruise
you know do this role i think would be
quite cool so all these nine characters
if i ask you to choose one which one
would you choose
100 professor i think that like having
him in in the mcu would be like an
amazing like bridgeway
i also happen to have here
four cards two of them dr strange and
scarlet witch who is not rumored they
are in the cast
and the two that you named professor x
okay so the idea here is this right
four of them one two three four are you
left handed right handed right handed
put on your right hand like this okay
fantastic
i'm gonna give you scarlet witch and
doctor strange okay that's the first one
scarlet witch i'm gonna place it on your
palm like this okay the other one is
doctor strange okay so you are holding
on to doctor strange and scarlet witch
which means i'm holding on to
fantastic now watch if i give it a tap
like this
you feel it happen right here now i'm
holding scarlet witch and doctor strange
take a look at your hand
oh my god there you go check them out
make sure they are what they seem to be
oh my god wow this is amazing
take a look
shut up
okay that's not fair
and what are you holding
any particular one you fancy
[Music]
professor x yes
we heard his voice inside the trailer
right okay good good very happy it's
coming back
yeah krasinski
you do know your act as well very good
that is photoshop yes
because real life white emily blunt
in storm that's right that's right
there will be a dream cast right there
will be
spiderman spiderman which which
spiderman do you prefer because the
internet is rumored to say that you know
andrew will be the one that
no no
same i like toby toby yes okay good good
okay so um if i was to ask you to pick
uh one character which one would it be
wolverine okay so we have loki
and wolverine
now
pack of cards here
this one where you take the cards in
your hands hold them in dealing position
as though you were gonna do cuts and i
wanted to start taking the cards and
placing them on the table one by one
anytime you feel like it you can just
stop
here you happy good now i'm going to
take loki put it here can you put all
the cards on top of loki
very good
okay sabrina right your turn take the
cards okay do the same deal the cards
down on the table one by one
and again at any time you feel like it
you can just stop
here happy with that i'll take wolverine
and i'll place him here put the rest of
the cards on top all very good
you could have stopped anywhere free
choice to do in fact you went a few more
right good now we're going to take the
cards that are facing each other right
okay so i'm going to spread through the
cards we have these two they are facing
each other right and then these two that
are facing each other okay
so we have loki and wolverine
watch this loki
perfect match loki and loki and then we
have wolverine
well done we have mr fantastic perfect
match and also
superior iron man perfect match
now i know why you might be thinking
about thinking
maybe the whole deck is made up of loki
and wolverine right
but
it's not it's actually made up of here
scarlet witch
we have american chavez we have wong we
have doctor strange each and every
single one of them they are all the cast
correctors and none of them are these
two
they are all in the cast all except for
these two
there you go you can check them out if
you like go ahead don't be shy thank you
very much
wolverine and wolverine
because you never see the rest of the
cards they are all the same they are
either wolverine and superior iron man
however they are not scarlet witch wong
in fact every single one of the cars
doctor strange each and every single one
of them there are no rumored cast on
this deck of cards so you had to stop
these two
these are the nine of the most rumored
characters we don't even know if they
are going to appear but these are what
the internet hopes to see in this movie
so now you are thinking of one of these
nine characters yes correct do you know
what's the famous doctor strange move he
can open portals
by doing this yes
i want you to do this with me
to the big screen over there go ahead
very good
look a portal opens fantastic
and that's me in another universe
did i get it
thank you very much
awesome spiderman did i get it
no
yes this is amazing
wow
did i get it yeah
thank you thank you very much thank you
chase
thank you so much for watching now i'm
going to go recharge my powers but
before i go don't forget to catch doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
coming on the theaters on the 4th of may
you guys take care stay safe and i'll
see you soon